scary baby let's go no matter what
happens guys at the end we
we're all friends and we can all kiss if
we want to [ __ ] hate you
i'm only friends with you for spencer
anyway okay
there's too many of you here i would
like to do the keys task
but i'm uncomfortable with the volume of
people who are currently doing the task
all right
okay cool oh somebody else will do that
right somebody else will do that
somebody else will do that ethan please
don't kill me ethan ethan please eat
them please
eve eve
i would be so sad if it kills me i would
be so sad
[Music]
what's up okay okay um i have a question
for dan
quick okay um
do you know if you have the t the key
task up at the top
uh oh
[Laughter]
okay okay can i butt in real quick i
have the key task i just did it dan was
with me the whole time
i don't know why it was really creeping
me out but he didn't just like be
close to you man i was on cams and i can
say that dan is doing the exact same
thing he did to me last round and he was
in his
[Laughter]
i saw him doing the exact same thing on
cams is it so bad to be afraid of dying
[Laughter]
i don't want to vote him but i i was
kind of checking if people were doing
keys and dan ran straight down so i
don't want to accuse him but
so dan if you don't know if one person
has keys everybody has keys
oh
no self report it's a self report
uh ross what the [ __ ]
out here doing my tasks yeah
dan seemed fine though he seemed okay um
we're gonna go up to
the laboratory hope that nobody kills me
probably ethan's already here probably
oh okay okay jack sean
okay that's that's okay
so what happened was i left admin i went
up because of the the lights
and then i realized that i because i did
the cutscene skip i had
still had keys so i ran up i did the
keys and then as i came down i couldn't
see the body because the lights were
still off but i saw the report button
and i hit it so that was right outside
of the entrance to like
uh what's it called in the electrical i
guess
man i feel like everybody could have
just killed me in a laboratory with the
lights out and didn't so i don't know
what's going on or is this a classic
skip on nine
no the classic skip feel like it is yeah
i think so
wait did anyone not dan what were you up
to
uh okay so i hit something called admin
it brought up a map and then i couldn't
figure out what to do with it so i
walked
away and then someone died you know that
only impostors can access the map right
that's naughty that's
wait are you admitting to it it's a good
attempt to get it is that true
that's a little bit of a spike have we
just gaslet dan into thinking he's an
impostor even though he's not he's like
the game must be wrong
oh yeah okay i've never been more
confused
wait so the lights are still [ __ ] off
is what you're telling me [ __ ]
i fixed the lights
that did not shoot the deputy all right
i'm gonna go to laboratory gonna try and
do the thing i was trying to do last
time
[ __ ] sake
wait i've already done it i've already
done it
that that's gonna look sauce to ross is
my bad it's my bad
somebody has some explaining to do i
just walked in with you alana and i just
came up and saw
the cyan body did you see who uh who was
walking away
uh anyone got any words that would like
to say did
alana did you see someone leaving the
other direction ethan
i saw you we used a little black avatar
just running away from a dead body
it was already in the room i went up to
uh i went up to [ __ ] what's it called
uh uh ethernet telescope there we go
uh we went up to the telescope i went up
to juice telescope
and i had the i had the like nebula
looking planet
you know i'm talking about and then i
went down uh
to go and do the wires over right in
front of decontamination
hey okay i do have a question with no
one else in the room when
uh so can i just say something that's us
yeah yeah
and this is it actually in uh ethan's
favor
when i walked up into the the
the medical area alana wasn't below the
body
doing the report she was above the body
roth that's what i was about to ask
because i was on vitals and i saw the
body die and then be reported very
quickly back to you
i think this is actually this is
100 ethan we just walked in on him
in the room when we were coming in to do
lights and we wouldn't stack on top we
just walked in to ethan in the room ross
okay you and i walked in there ethan was
trying to leave
what did you see on cam um i
all i can say is i saw aaron and alana i
didn't see
anyone else they were running in the
corridor of medical
damn
i there was a there was a pool of lava
and a little area that looked like a
diving board and i was like that's
that looks nice and i hung out there for
a while and then someone died
hey is your name red
no wait what no what don't do this
that's so mean you're wasting time i
literally walked in on ethan
dead body on the floor and he tries to
leave it's to tell you it's not me and
then next round
next round you're voting for ethan
that's all i'm saying yeah that's what
i'm saying and you can all go [ __ ]
yourself i do think it is
wait decks are all wrong yeah they are
oh oh that's funny ethan vote for her
someone should just go and press a
button and
a report ether that's i can't believe
that i just saw that happen
and and and i said i said it to everyone
crank couple hi
all right what oh
it's definitely ethan definitely do it
what proof do you have huh oh my eyes
and my ears dude
all right well explain how that worked
huh oh well i saw it and then you
i was going up the reactor and i was
scared i was scared for my life and i
see you do something
bad i'm thinking it's a self-report guys
because
here's the thing here's the thing any
witnesses any witnesses it was
too yeah two witnesses are against you
well i saw it too listen what color am i
black okay okay well here's the thing
i happen to know that both jaden and
albert are color blind
they can't actually sing the color black
and i'm a girl
actually it's actually true
blue it's actually not against me i
trust
he is a girl with my life thank you
jaden
i don't trust ethan with anything
because he did it and there's no truth
it was a self-report guys so uh-uh
albert just vote albert just vote dude
oh i didn't know i was the last one
i don't think you have to convince the
murderer that he's a murderer
i uh yeah i kind of i kind of threw that
because i already knew that i was gonna
get married
i cannot [ __ ] believe it [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't think the other person
is though
what you doing dan
you just hanging out bud you gonna
murder ross
what's what's seems like a man doing
tasks
who else is a murderer is what i would
like to know
with this you can you can make a kill
right here you could do this no okay
nothing okay anyone no jayden seems to
be doing tasks
that seems like behavior of a of a
crewmate
it's definitely not albert otherwise he
wouldn't have reported it right
there is murder happening
ah it's maybe alpha maybe
it is alpha
oh good kill bro good kill
i can't i'm so mad at ross i'm so upset
that he was like but a lot of walked
into the room and reported the body
yeah i saw ethan running out
[ __ ] chucks can somebody please tell
me how to log
the goddamn temperature i have no idea
how to do this you just have to match it
and then what that's it you just have to
make them the same
yeah put it oh it goes
make numbers same negative dude
okay how many people is dead oh
alpha what's the plan yeah why didn't
you kill jd
what do you i think you could have done
it
i think he would have been okay
you just gotta you just gotta find
anyone really right that's the plan you
just gotta [ __ ]
oh uh i don't trust alpha with my life
anymore
why whoa
holy crap
oh yeah i am why don't you trust me with
your life
because you weren't following me and
then albert and you disappeared together
and now he's dead
and so is many other people
yeah there's a lot of people dead i'm
gonna say i don't think it's ross
i don't think dan has the capability of
killing this many people
then you're probably right i think it's
jaden because i also haven't been with
her the entire game
oh no oh so it's definitely jacob
i mean yeah jacob i like i actually
hear the fear in jayden's voice so i'm
going to vote with her
can can i give him one second can i have
the floor
yeah go ahead
what what is all right i was like what
is my defense
where did albert go oh
[Laughter]
i i honestly was gonna pin it on dan and
then jaden said
i don't think he could have done this
and i go uh well
i was literally like i walked in on
someone who had clearly just ran away
from a dead body and you were like it
seems like it might be a lot what if
yours
no come on